vous avez parlé de l'indépendance du
parquet et de la réforme du csm
je voulais vous demander car vous avez
sans doute pris des engagements lors de
l'acceptation de ce poste si vous pouvez
vous engager à ce que d'ici la fin de ce
mandat soit véritablement déposer une
loi constitutionnelle elle a déjà été
voté par les deux assemblées de telle
manière qu'elles puissent venir au
congrès pour être rapidement voté
ma position monsieur le sénateur avait
été extrêmement clairs je suis pour une
séparation nette du siège et du parquet
une formule que j'ai très souvent
utilisé formule du président coo jarre
qui préside la cour d'assises de paris
qui disait c'est quand même le seul
sport où l'un des arbitres portent le
même maillot qu'un des joueurs j'ai dit
d'ailleurs que dans la magistrature
on est plus sur une position univoque là
dessus il ya un certain nombre de
magistrats qui souhaitent la séparation
du siège et du parquet moi c'est mon
souhait pour un tas de raisons je n'ai
sans doute pas le temps de les
développer ici mais nous nous reverrons
je ne pourrais pas le faire parce que je
mange mon chapeau mais le temps qui
m'est imparti m'interdit de 2,2 m 7
cette modification essentielle à mes
yeux en chantier oui alors oui mais oui
oui oui oui oui je jeu avec ans déjà
non sur la nuque alors je voudrais
terminer ce que ce que ce qui me semble
réformes structurelles essentielles que
je ne pourrais pas mené à son terme
non pas que je n'en ai pas envie mais ce
sont des rêves ou des utopies que le
calendrier me contraint à mettre de côté
mais oui mais vous m'avez posé des
questions sur le reste je vous réponds
sur le reste je voulais aussi évidemment
envisager l'école nationale de la
magistrature et envisager une école de
formation commune non mais ce sont des
choses importantes
je pourrais pas en vente sur l'
ordonnance de 58 les magistrats et
particulièrement ceux du parquet
attentes ces prêts forme et il s'agit
d'inscrire de graver dans le marbre de
la constitution
une pratique que ce pouvoir a toujours
respecté
voilà donc la réponse est oui vous nous
annoncer aujourd'hui que le président de
la république va convoquer le congrès
pour faire adopter définitivement cette
révision de la constitution qui avait
été voté en termes identiques par les
deux chambres
c'est ce qu'il a dit 7
c'est un scoop je vous remercie
il ya une précision motorisés vous
monsieur le président je vous le demande
aa précisé à monsieur le sénateur sûr
que la réforme constitutionnelle
évidemment je le souhaite c'est
évidemment le président qui décide de
réunir le congrès vous vous savez met
les choses au mieux en leur précisant et
et est d'accord
non mais ce que j'ai dit au président de
la république est ce qu'il m'a dit voilà
il n'a pas à être dévoilés ici on a bien
c'est peut-être une de mes dernières
plaidoiries alors voilà monsieur le
ministre est ce que j'attendais mes
chers collègues je voudrais conclure
cette séance si le ministre a terminé
pour eux les réponses qu'il veut nous
apporte où je suis sur la nomination des
procureurs et la réunion du congrès par
le président de la république j'avais
cru comprendre que vous étiez autorisé à
annoncer sa prochaine réunion
vous avez bien fait d'apporter une
précision pour que nous ne restions pas
sur une impression fausse 20e min
secondes
oui bien sûr je vais rappeler dans mon
discours introductif ce propos qui
étaient un peu long que l'on pouvait
modifier les choses de façon le
référendum je crois ou la réunion du
congrès et qu'il appartiendrait comme
vous me le rappeler et je vous en sais
gré et qu'il appartenait au président de
la république de choisir cela n'est pas
une annonce
les choses sont donc c'est le rappel de
de nos règles les choses sont
parfaitement vrai